what would you say is the biggest
difference between the Taylor shoe
pictured when you were first offered the
role for Captain Marvel and who he has
turned out to be in secret Invasion and
maybe Beyond look it's it's it's an
utterly you know like there's been an
evolution there which was which was vast
not completely unexpected I took the job
because it was Ryan and Anna who I'd
done a film with um and they said would
you come and do this and I was like you
know like sure you know
um and you know I I knew I'd had a brief
time there he was going to die on page
56 and here we are so
it's been like it's awesome it's been
one of the great working uh honors of my
life is to be in this
um in this you know what what I what is
considered the greatest contemporary
um film company you know the studio on
Earth and
you know it's just it's uh it's awesome
at this point so far after Captain
Marvel are you able to reveal how he
died in that original script
oh yeah it was like I mean like there
was a there was a um I mean there was a
yeah basically those crease those creep
punks came on in and started some drama
and then one of the things that happened
was that he you know he he fought he he
gets done in that time you know we we
understand a little bit about what's
going on but that's you know that's it
he's gone he's gone I'm glad that was
changed me too so you bring up uh Ryan
and uh Anna I'm curious is there
anything about your collaboration with
them and what it brought out in the
character that you have found yourself
holding tight to especially tight too
that we could see reflected in your
secret Invasion performance but then
also what is something about your your
collaboration with Ali that has added
something new to the character that
maybe you didn't expect that's a great
question I think that I talked with Ron
and Anna who were were familiar with
with it with the whole project and uh
and you know and one of the things which
which which Anna had said to me was just
you know like make sure that we find a
way to keep that humor because I
referred back to them as the original
kind of you know creators of this I you
know and so that is something that we
find you you're not seeing a lot of it
you know at this time but you will come
to see parts of it now what's changed
about it is this is a guy who really has
the weight of the world on his shoulders
and
um and the humor is a lot more like
traditional Australian human which is
like you know which is you know derisive
kind of
um humor but you know
it's just awesome when you get to do it
with Sam it's awesome the answer to this
next question might be a no but it's not
very often that someone literally gets
the opportunity to walk in somebody
else's shoes and Talos has done that
with Nick Fury so is there anything
about that experience that now makes
Talos I don't know rethink what kind of
person Nick Fury is or maybe have a
different perspective on what his job is
like that's a that's a fantastic
question and you know the thing about
like like like the one of the wonderful
things about the what's happened in this
entire thing is that the the far from
home was was unexpected for me like that
as as its reveal that yeah yeah I
carried the ball for you the whole time
but what I think he really learns about
what Furies had to go through or who he
is and isn't is what taylos tells him
when we're gonna get you're going to see
it you're gonna see who Nick Fury is and
what what taylos has brought to the
table as to who he is and that I think
is to me one of the great Pleasures
about who this guy actually ends up
being in the MCU who the Scrolls end up
being in the MCU versus who they are in
the in the can the canonical works you
know so excited to see that evolve I'm
I'm so excited to see the two characters
evolve as well but I think Sam is one of
the greatest working actors in this
business I'm such a huge fan of his so
I'm curious to hear a little bit about
your collaboration as actors what is
something about him as a scene partner
that makes him stand out from all the
other incredible actors you've worked
with and you know maybe even something
he does to help you access something in
your own character that you can't reach
without him Sam is effortlessly Sam is
just like one of the coolest humans that
ever got on a screen and Sam is someone
that the you know if you saw jungle
fever you if you caught him back then
and he and you and you and you
understand and you saw him in Jurassic
Park you saw and then you understand
that this guy has ended up becoming the
box office winner of the entire human
race and it's unlikely as things stand
that that will ever be broken this man
is a man of such uh achievements and yet
such kind of
you know there's a you know because the
great thing about working with Sam is
every now and then you just see these
slightly different kind of you see these
slightly different versions of him and
it's just really special to be able to
kind of
because that's one of the best things
about the job full stop you get to go to
work and go oh
look who's there and you also get to
complain all day if you like you still
get paid the same money
um but to be able to do that and to just
be around and to have a kind of uh you
know relationship where you know we talk
a bit of you know talk a bit of rubbish
together and whatnot but Sam
makes you better Sam makes you better
because you are
you are acting across one of the you
know one of the you know most important
people uh in terms of screen acting of
our time and you don't you know you
don't pass that sort of stuff up lightly
and you don't half step if you can avoid
it literally the highest possible
compliment you could give to a seed
partner I love it it's you know he's
that's that's Samuel L Jackson you make
me even prouder of my Sam Jackson
Jurassic Park tattoo
right that's the thing that's the thing
people forget people forget I can't
forget it it's on me for the rest no but
I know but that's the thing about him he
labored in those fields and that's him
Jurassic Park smoking them cigarettes